glace bonsoir merci d'être là vous
voulez publié aux presses de la
renaissance le fils du chiffonnier sont
vos mémoires traduit de l'américain par
bernard ferry et jeanne moreau vous
parler précisément de jeanne moreau
car vous avez voulu un certain moment la
faire tourner dans spartacus
oui c'est vrai mais d'abord je voudrais
dire que je suis fier d'être ici ce soit
parce que c'est bien qu'ils aient quand
on écrit on livre on ne vient pas et qui
vint comme dans mon métier si on fait on
fume on n'est pas une vedette mais j'ai
très heureuse d'être ici avec mes vrais
écrivains et c'est vrai que dans mon
livre j'ai écrit je me souviens très
bien de jean marot je voudrais qu'elle
violerait danse pas je suis venu ici
avec ma femme à paris pour parler avec
eux avec elle et elle est en train de
faire une pièce de théâtre est dit que
c'est un groupe très important c'est ce
parc c'est avec toni wilen ustinov mais
elle dit que je dois faire les la pièce
de théâtre pour un mois de plus j'ai
demandé combien ça coûte
pour moi ce n'était pas pas beaucoup
j'ai dit je vais le p mais elle m'a dit
non mais plus tard j'ai trouvé qu'elle
était amoureuse quelqu'un c'est à cause
de ça mais ça peut arriver peut-être à
paris je crois dans mon pays
si une actrice si elle al'occasion de
jumeaux comme rocky jean semaine à la
fin qu'elle a joué je crois qui elle est
amoureuse de quelqu'un
elle va jouer l'euro parce qu'en france
les actrices françaises préfèrent
d'abord will et oui les la passion avant
le cinéma turc huawei et voudra compter
d'ailleurs notre le cameroun jeanne
moreau vous l'avez trouvé terriblement
sensuelle et que lorsque vous avez dansé
avec elle chez maxim vous l'atteignez
éloignés alors pourtant que vous n'avez
pas peur des femmes
on verra ça dans un moment quand vous
avez appris le français
deux mois jour pour un film oui je suis
arrivé ici il y a plus que 35 ans je ne
parle pas français je ne vois pas très
bien maintenant mais à ce moment là
j'étais égoïste
maintenant je ne suis pas égoïste je
suis très très près mais je suis très
calme mais à ce moment là j'étais en
train de faire une l'acte d'amour pour
tout le look back avec avec denis robin
et brigitte bardot elle a joué un petit
rôle dans le fermé il voudrait le faire
dans deux visions j'ai dit moi je vais
le faire en français dit oui oui et dire
oui ou non papa français j'ai dit que je
vais l'apprendre comme ça j'ai trouvé
une femme s'appelle madame la fouille
même la fin j'ai travaillé avec la 2e
pajot comme ça j'avais appris et en deux
mots appris le français et puis c'est en
france que vous avez vous avez déniché
votre deuxième femme anne qui est
d'ailleurs ici présentes sur ce sur ce
plateau
et si c'est ça qui est typiquement
française oui c'est à cause de ça que
moi vous savez de temps en temps je me
sens on peut foncer
j'ai fait le premier voyage en europe 7
à paris j'ai fait un film
la chose la plus important que j'ai fait
la connaissance de ma femme après ça à
cause d'elle j'ai fait plusieurs choses
avec le fait ce week-end avec les césar
on m'a donné légion d'honneur
je me sens tout petit peu français
my way que je suis vraiment marqué nous
sommes très contents que vous senti un
peu français nous sommes très honorés
je vous présente les des écrivains qui
sont avec vous à votre droite c'est
vladimir volkoff dont le prénom et le
nom indique bien les origines russes
on verra ça aussi tout à l'heure pour
vous écrivain traduit dans le monde
entier
son nouveau roman s'intitule les hommes
du dard publié aux éditions de fallois
et l'âge d'homme alors vous avez là en
face de moi la star de la publicité
française s'appelle jacques séguéla
c'est lui c'est lui qui a fait de
françois mitterrand une star rien que ça
et il publie demain il sera trop tard
aux éditions flammarion
et puis alors en face de vous un
écrivain qui est célèbre depuis 30 ans
en france
il est très intelligent il est très doué
il est évidemment très contestée c'est
normal il s'appelle philippe sollers et
il publie un roman le leader aux
éditions gallimard et des carnets carnet
de nuit aux éditions plon
et puis jérôme garcin qui est
journaliste il a été producteur et
animateur d'émissions littéraires sur
fr3 c'est la troisième chaîne télévision
actuellement rédacteur en chef à
l'événement du jeudi responsable des
pages culturelles
vous êtes critique littéraire provençal
et vous n'êtes publié le dictionnaire
aux éditions françois bourin
alors vous allez expliquer à kirk
douglas l'idée originale drôle cruel et
perverse qui est à la naissance de ce
livre expliquez-lui est ce que les
cruelles ça c'est une fois ce que vous
dites mais c'est pas évident là au point
de départ je me suis dit qu'il y avait
finalement pas de deux créateurs
ça peut être un écrivain sont les
écrivains ici mais ça pourrait être des
peintres ou d'autres d'autres créateurs
qui n'est un moment donné l'obsession de
savoir ce qu'il restera de sa vie ou de
son oeuvre
après sa mort en fait je me suis dit les
écrivains sont souvent obsédé par l'idée
de la mortalité de la postérité mais
finalement ils n'ont jamais l'occasion
de savoir ce qu'il restera de après leur
disparition et je me suis dit on va
demander aux écrivains de rédiger leur
propre notice de dictionnaires mais à la
troisième personne
c'est à dire que ce serait douglas kirk
par carl douglas à la troisième personne
ce qui n'est pas évident je me promet il
au lieu de le faire la première personne
jeu comme vous le faites dans votre
livre c'est la troisième personne et
donc voilà c'était le pari du des livres
et vous demandez troisième personne que
soi bref et que ce soit sérieux
oui voilà et vous avez obtenu 250
réponse qu'il m'aime moi me sidère oui
disait que tout le monde allez vous vous
envoyer une fin de non recevoir pour un
truc aussi délirant mais pas du tout non
mais parce que je crois encore passé il
ya un livre récent qui a paru deux cas
daninos où il dit que
souvent ils à la nuit révèle une chose
c'est d'aller dans un journal pour
ouvrir ce qu'on appelle affreusement le
frigidaire dans lequel il y a les futurs
nécrologie pour à la lettre des voir ce
qui a écrit à daninos et en priant dieu
que le même jour ne meurt pas une star
du cinéma parce que au calcaire est
relégué en dernière page du journal et
je crois que ça explique aussi un tout
petit peu ce fantasme là explique un peu
pourquoi facilement les gens se sont
prêtés au jeu y compris la troisième
personne en face ce n'était pas évident
on faisait quand même essuyé des refus
il ya ensuite des cayrol mais d'autres
là quand même oui n'en citer que deux là
où croît jean les gens déjà soigné non
mais le seigneur beckett a refusé voilà
c'est normal mais non mais jean cayrol
non mais beaucoup ont refusé parce qu'il
n'arrivait pas à le faire c'est à dire
qu'il ne voulait pas et voulait
respecter la règle comme cayrol comme
d'autres écrivains mais il n'avait pas à
le faire
bon alors certains effectivement n'ont
pas pu se plier à la règle de la
troisième personne ils ont fait ça la
première personne certains autres un peu
triché comme blondin qui a repris le
questionnaire est bon il ya un petit peu
de tout mais ce qui est vrai c'est que
d'abord certains ont été confrontés à
l'idée de la date de leur mort certains
l'ont mise oui c'est à dire qu'il ya
environ un tiers des réponses qui
comporte la date de naissance et la date
présumée des morts la plus la date la
plus proche et 1993 date à laquelle
devrait disparaître jean-jacques
brochier la plus lointaine je crois que
c'est 2019 que je sais plus quel
écrivain se voit centenaire mais
beaucoup ont décidé de mettre un terme à
leur vie
vous parlez dans votre préface de fausse
modestie d'incroyables prétentions de
certains je dis pas après à prétention
incroyable prétention si tu nous avais
voulu réaliser à venise et encore mieux
que moi
oui on voit je peux me toujours de
tromper enfin il m'a semblé quand même
attention
oui et non je crois pas d'abord peu
importe non parce que par égard pour les
auteurs non mais oui c'est pas peut-être
tête dans l'événement du jeu c'est la
corrigibles prétention à l'accord y fait
attention mais je crois que très
franchement un écrivain un vrai écrivain
est fier de ce qu'il fait c'est vrai que
alors on peut dire qu'ils sont parfois
narcissique parfois un peu un peu
prétentieux mais je trouve ça en fait
assez normal et en jouant le jeu ils ont
prouvé que pour la première fois ils
portaient sur leur vie sur leur oeuvre
un regard panoramique et certains en
sont fiers sagan superbe légal s'est
inscrit très beau c'est que ce n'est pas
simplement une réponse c'est son
épitaphe fille sagan françoise 1935 puis
on ne sait pas si son apparition en 1954
avec un mince roman bonjour tristesse
qui fut un scandale mondial
sa disparition après une vie à une
oeuvre également agréable et bâclée ne
fut un scandale que pour elle même ce
qui est super et aussi très belle
réponse déchets noz rinaldi qui sont des
réponses courtes et christian judee sill
eafe sans alexandre mais je n'y vois pas
bladimir volkov alors solaire totale à
mon sens grâce à 10 enfin avant de
répondre
c'est vrai aussi il ya un an j'ai très
très belle réponse de mian kundera par
exemple sur adèle le clézio qui n'a pas
joué le jeu
la troisième a fait une belle à la
première personne et il y a je le dis
très franchement il y à des oublis la
d1000 volkov j'allais oublier bon j'ai
oublié gênant mais je le dis aussi
franchement d'abord je ne suis pas
invité ici je le répète comme écrivain
mais comme journaliste c'est c'est un
travail de journaliste et pas de
d'écrivains de lire la préface et vous
protégera d'un haut niveau de ma vie d
une seconde fois donc là dessus c'est
clair mais c'est vrai que comme livre de
journaliste j'ai voulu qu'il soit fait
vite mais c'est vrai que j'ai fait une
liste d'écrivain et que je regrette
beaucoup d'absences vladimir volkoff
zimmermann ya beaucoup d'autres vous
auriez répondu je ne crois pas non non
non je crois qu'il faut faire son métier
qu un écrivain doit faire son oeuvre et
non pas sa biographie je pense que nous
aurons tous tous ceux d'entre nous qui
valent quelque chose auront leur
biographe après leur mort et c'est trop
tôt encore pour faire nos biens
graff et et si on vous avait demandé
c'est jacques séguéla vous l'auriez fait
ah non parce que je me considère pas
comme un écrivain mais avant moi
j'applaudis à l'idée publicitaires quand
même formidable c'est fini les
publicitaires c'est quand même 250 pages
de pub admirable comme les publicitaires
ne réussiront jamais à en faire d'une
potée j'ai trouvé c'est un petit peu
long dans l'ensemble et que les
écrivains c'est leur métier en du mal à
faire cours par exemple blondin il a
repris le questionnaire mais la dernière
phrase de blonay c'était remettez nous
ça c'est formidable
non votre devise oui répond remettez ça
alors moi ce n'est pas compréhensible
formidable polak dit un peu plus loin
touche à tout il a fini par toucher
terre il suffisait de mettre ces deux
lignes tout le reste finalement de finir
cas qu'à s'ouvrir la shoah oui mais vous
avez vu que certains quand même se
prennent pour des stars
oui mais un et star défunte puisqu'ils
ont joué le jeu mais bien sûr mais je
crois je crois d'ailleurs que les
écrivains vont devenir les grandes stars
dépendre le relais de beaucoup de stars
d'aujourd'hui à bord est tant mieux
vladimir volkoff oui donc que vous
n'êtes pas dans l'eau ne sera pas ma
faim vous avez dû vous avez dit que vous
ne soyez pas et les hommes du dard
pourquoi avez vous alors je disais
évidemment vous êtes d'origine russe
vladimir volkoff non le projet d'ériger
la cacher ses vinyles égalé à partir de
glace là un peu cachée mais on verra ça
tout à l'heure le bon pourquoi vous
êtes-vous me plonger dans la russie d'
ivan le terrible
parce que pour les gens qui sont pétris
de culture russe c'est une période qui
est c'est un peu comme louis xiii et
richelieu pour les français c'est la
période sur laquelle un nombre infini
des rondes et écrite donc j'ai grandi à
l'ombre du vent terrible j'ai lu vos je
pourrais vous citer toutes les oeuvres
ne sommes pas là pour ça et cette
période qui a vraiment existé est aussi
devenu une sorte de période mythique des
biens mythologique sur laquelle
pratiquement tous les écrivains russes
ont remis de style ce qui est léon
tolstoï honte écrit j'ai eu envie de
partager ce schmitz est privilégiée avec
les lecteurs français que lui ne connaît
pas très bien je n'ai aucune envie de
transposer cette inspiration limiter à
cette période qui est une période
passionnante puisque ce n'est pas
seulement ivan le terrible
c'est la guerre contre la pologne à la
guerre contre la suède a raconté
les suédois les tartares sont les
intrigues qui se tisse autour de la
russie c'est la naissance de la russie
moderne
j'ai eu envie de partager cette période
presque mythologique avec le public
français
oui bon bien entendu il ya ivan le
terrible qui est un personnage
formidable qui a souvent été racontée
dans d'autres livres mais là ce qui me
paraît important dans votre roman ce
sont deux personnages dont vous raconter
l'irrésistible ascension il y en a qui
est connue qui s'appelle boris godounov
qui va d'ailleurs devenir le le désarmer
après après parlement dans une suite de
se re manche pour une suite j'espère
enfin l'aller la période est très riche
et effectivement puis l'autre personnage
qui est à fait fascinant j'espère qu'il
a existé vous ne l'avez pas inventé qui
s'appelle l'obsar on revient encore il
s'appelle sarre ps
ar c'est pas le dire le pss à risques
expliquait sous des capes ça alors là je
suis désolé de vous décevoir mais je les
ai inventées à vous l'avez inventé c'est
dommage c'est à dire que là ça dépend
pour qui désire que non parce que
j'aurais voulu qu'il est vécu comme un
bravo alors je dis bravo bravo pour le
monde ça veut dire valait de chiens il
ya en russe un proverbe qui est d'une
profonde sagesse mon avis et qui dit à
peu près ceci je vais traduire ce n'est
pas tout de plaire aux tsars
il faut aussi plaire aux valets de
chiens c'est à dire ne suis pas
d'adressé de s'adresser au bon dieu il
faut quelquefois s'adressait à ses
saintes c&g supposer qu'il y avait à
l'époque d' ivan le terrible un valet de
chiens un bsaar dont il vend terrible
qui a beaucoup aimé élevé les gens aient
tiré du ruisseau et offert de grands
seigneurs et très souvent le contraire
ils vont aux terribles le désir d'élever
ses tomes de le tirer c'est un c'est le
dernier derby c'est le dernier les
derniers partir d'une parole de
l'évangile appartient de parole de
l'évangile ivan le terrible ouvre
l'évangile lee les premiers seront les
derniers et d'airé seront les premiers
et dit je dois faire comme l'évangile
alors il dit qui est le dernier autour
de moi on lui dit bah c'est le dernier
des vallées de chien est il très bien je
vais en faire un grand seigneur est
vraiment celle essentiellement cela
c'est l'ascension de ce ballet de chiens
bon à qui il va lui donner la fille
d'une princesse et l'obligé à se marier
or à l'extérieur cette info ce
personnage soudain charge sur un chien
oui et il devient le chien du tsar oui
tout à fait il est dévoué aux arts ea
mai
dans sa vie familiale vous en faites un
homme tout à fait recommandable agréable
bon mari d'une part j'aime beaucoup les
chiens c'est une première raison est
comme des gens qui s'occupent des chiens
doivent finir par ressembler un peu au
chien c'est normal je crois qu'ils
ressentent cet incident et il a ses
qualités de fidélité c'est il suffit de
le braquer dans une direction pour qu'il
y aille c'est un chien bien dressé mais
en même temps il à cette douceur cette
tendresse très secrète des chiens
effectivement cette relation avec sa
femme sur une relation très réussi mais
surtout il regardera l'odeur du chien
toute sa vie faut dire que la première
scène ces cantons le des crasses on
enlève tout ce qu'il a sur lui de crasse
de tous de vraiment de petites bêtes
c'est une superbe scène il sentira le
chien jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
oui messieurs dames à cyrano con c'est à
cause de cette vivre je ne peux pas là
les mêmes de monsieur volkov
c'est à cause d'eux à nicolas aussi que
je suis ici ce soit parce que mes
parents et mes récits je sais tout et
c'est à cause de l'absence d'une salle
alexandre iii celle qui crachent sur le
point alors à côté de sa fille sur le
pont à la rive à paris formidable
vous êtes sur le point l'exemple de 3
vous dites quel bouffon qui vous
rappeler que c'est sud sahara qui fait
hier me suis rendu compte que j'adore le
pont alexandre iii
je crois que c'est le plus beau pont de
paris mais après ça j'ai appris que le
zares l agent me 3 il est vrai moins
vrai très intéressé meti et pour ça je
le déteste à la fois j'aime beaucoup le
prend et vous avez craché sur le pont
barbe des piques entre contres bien
demandé à jacques séguéla qui notre
expert en star le jazz c'est quand même
une grande star il disait tout à l'heure
une conne elle ne sait pas le mot vient
sur le
ils n'étaient pas star parce que les
médias n'hésitaient pas enfin les médias
le petit écran qui est là et qui a
finalement inventé le mot star d'abord
au cinéma et puis à la télévision mais
c'était d'immenses stars et moi je
voudrais dire combien j'ai adoré le
livre de volkov baroque picaresque
romantique riche truculent c'est la
sagrada familia se promènent là dedans
et derrière chaque personnage un autre
personnage qui se cache
et puis il est inachevée bah oui c'est
pour ça que j'ai c'est qu'il reste
parlement une suite oui c'est formidable
alors oui les louis les ladies a arrêté
avant je crois que le moteur d assécher
du cri c'est lui qui a déjà tout inventé
de notre système arrivé déjà le roi
navision ya déjà eu laurent david orr
oui mais enfin il était peut-être moi
moins fort en communication qualité
jésus-christ et puis le lézard qui avait
d'ailleurs tous leurs courtisans qui
était en fait leurs médias les médias de
l'époque c'était les pétards et les
autres je vais demander à notre critique
littéraire qui est ici qui est jérôme
garcin parce que vous êtes quand même
pas critique littéraire vous avez
d'examiner les villes et lecteurs jérôme
garcin qu'est ce que vous pensez du vous
avez oublié volkov alors là je trouve
c'est un très beau roman historique à
aider des scènes magiques comme j'allais
très marquée par la scène du décrassage
parce que vous n'êtes pas scène
d'anthologie à trois femmes qui le
décrit ec2 nous allons absolument
extraordinaire j'ai trouvé il ya des
chasses superbe
moi je laissais très mal cette période
je dis très simplement le xvième siècle
en russie
j'avais lu juste la biographie de divin
terrible par troyat ouï-dire vous citez
à la fin je trouve c'est un trait c'est
un très beau roman ce que je ne vois pas
très bien sait où vous voulez en venir
s'il ya des xia des conclusions vous
voulez en tirer sur le parce que c'est
vrai qu'en même temps ceux de sarlat il
est à la fois fascinant vous le rende et
fascinant inquiétant aussi notamment
vers la fin est ce que finalement vous
trouvez qu'il a été si c'est
extraordinaire que ça extraordinaire
sûrement et heureusement d'ailleurs
malheureusement qu'ils n'avaient pas
tous comme ça mais il n'y a aucun il n'y
a aucun message il n'y a aucune leçon en
tirer c'est pas une parabole c'est une
histoire c'est un roman
allez vous tirer les trois mousquetaires
la faute il faut dire que après la mort
du tsar
boris godounov et puis le blizzard celui
qui est un ancien valet de chiens voeux
vont devenir allier allier pour diriger
la russie d vous faites de boris
godounov l'assassin du fils illégitime
du tsar mais là j'ai vu que vous êtes
honnêtes et vous dites que cette version
est contestée
c'est une c'est la version
traditionnelle c'était la version de 46
au début du 19ème c'est la version de
pouchkine ses relations de tolstoï c'est
ce qu'on a toujours cru pendant 150 ans
et la version de l'opéra de bouloc ski
alors peut-on avoir raison contre
l'opéra de moussorsgki je ne le crois
pas je crois qu'il faut reprendre même
si c'est pas vrai il faut dire ce qu'a
dit moussorgski certains historiens
modernes le conteste mais moi je fais
une oeuvre d'art j'ai juste voulu savoir
si les volkov dont vous parlez à les
deux autres poissons sont vos ancêtres
ou pas oui oui et ça m'a beaucoup amusé
parce que dans la mesure où moi j'ai
inventé le personnage d'obsaar inventé
ça veut dire découvrir alors ça m'a
amusé de mettre en scène deux frères
volkov qui effectivement sont mes
ancêtres qui n'invente pas mais découvre
ce personnage le tir de la boue dans
lequel il est bon c'est un petit jeu de
retard va pas très loin mais c'est vrai
que la russie que vous faites le
portrait c'est une russie du de faire de
feu de sang de félonie
avec ces cartes mancienne qui disent
l'avenir qu'ils voient j'aide à peu près
la russie de catherine de médicis de la
saint barthélemy c'est la brède
l'angleterre delà des douars 6 enfin
septième lot d'abord ivan le terrible un
film splendide et le rapide ensuite
c'est moi je trouve que le roman est
particulièrement intéressant parce qu'il
montre notamment un
un moment comment l'obsession mais de ça
ces roms n'est ce pas c'est à dire le
saint siège et la politique la politique
d'europe moscou va t elle être la
troisième homme ou bien est ce qu'on
voit c'est une polémique traite c'est
une polémique très actuel en russie
aujourd'hui puisque vous savez comme moi
que les anti occidentaux très
réactionnaire en russie aujourd'hui ne
veulent pas se ce rallye entre les
ennemis au four de gorbatchev autres
stars dont nous parlerons peut-être tout
à l'heure de jésus-christ à gorbatchev
dit séguéla peut-être de façon un tout
petit peu l'euphorie des mois qui était
aussi déjà de jeanne d'arc à la brigitte
bardot que voilà alors donc le ce qui
est intéressant ce qui a gelé huit
isabelle procès vinolas vous décrivez ça
très bien et on est réhabilité
l'obsession des divans le terrible ccc
ce rhum mais ce rhum qui apparaît très
en avance sur cette rue c'est ça qui est
très intéressant nous sommes à rome il
ya michel-ange il ya montaigne où vous
parliez laisser grégoire xiii le pape il
est contemporain ya mariame dia
montaigne qui est dans le voyage en
italie qui va voir quelle heure tu as
their own et on voit la différence qu'il
était très problématique aujourd'hui
parce que c'est énorme retard de la
russie c'était l'ombre d'art de la
russie qui chassent probablement les
gens comme i / daniel vit à ici présents
mais rares étaient ceux là et on voit
bien la différence avec avec l'italie
avec l'italie de l'époque qui est en
plein alors expansion civilisation n'y a
pas de rigueur de comparaison et c'est
pour ça que votre mort est intéressant
car ils m'ont pardon régler ce problème
qui va être un énorme retard de la
russie pas terrible non plus n'avait
pendant ces derniers disent sûrs danielo
vici cyclo assure daniel beasche donc
votre prénom c'était issue retenant
danilovic vous êtes né en 1916 dans
l'état de new york d'une famille juive
très très pauvre vous dites même vous
avez eu faim oui ça arrive avec beaucoup
de gens en amérique c'est pas rares et
quand j'ai dit mais vous savez pour moi
quand j'écris les livres ils n'étaient
pas ceux ci on va le publier moi je
l'écris parce que je voudrais savoir qui
je suis parce que toute ma vie pour coca
rendront j'ai fait de furnes
je vis dans le monde fantasy et illusion
toujours notre gros effet très facile
d'oublier l'origine c'est à cause de ça
j'ai commencé à écrire le livre de
penser à mon origine j'ai trouvé que je
suis un sna avant vers je suis fier il
suffirait de mon registre suffire pour
mes parents et que ma cause bien sûr
contre ja ils sont venus où je ne peux
pas les et ne peut pas écrire malgré
tout ça je suis allé dans l'université
et je ne veux pas l'oublier mais que moi
je suis le fils les chiffonniers et
scènes que je trouve admirable
vous avez ai appris à votre mère à
écrire son nom le nom oui oui
non ma mère brahim j'ai grandi j'ai en
instruit je présente le support
wolfenstein qui est traducteur parce que
le club douglas qui parle très bien de
france vous avez il avait besoin de
secours au cas où
parce que je me fais de moi un yes we le
nom brahim b et a
et c'est un nom de ma compagnie et comme
j'ai écrit dans mon livre on joue quand
je suis arrivé j'ai ma mère elle avait
les autres immigrés autour des rites
fier de moi
des regards mon fils comme il est
important son nom dedans mais lumières
et a dit la mairie c'est vraiment un
pays spécial et j'étais embarrassée et
des moments où je sais bien que
l'amérique est spécial je vais je vais
montrer ton nom est mieux en ce moment
et on non après j'ai pris ma mère à new
york dans un an
voiture et on s'arrête devant gros
réclame l ai dit tu vois ton nom que
tout appris à cause de moi comment on
doit les crises et brain avec la lumière
et lebron james sparrow et ma mère dit à
la maison
l'amérique c'est vraiment un pays très
spécial
vous avez remarqué combien il a été un
but à l'antisémitisme
c'est ça ça veut dire ce que bon on
parlait de l'antisémitisme russe médecin
terme et alors là la description que
fait michael douglas de l'antisémitisme
waes c'est tout à fait extraordinaire il
a été en butte à sa très tôt il commence
à se faire casser la figure à l'école
comme jésus-christ qui l'apprécient
fiemme il ne sait même pas qui est
jésus-christ donc qu'il rentre chez lui
avec intel sont illégaux liés mais qui
est jésus après et après il se retrouve
à l'université et il va très vite c'est
à dire que le problème avec lui c'est
qu'il n'a pas il y lire bien souvent il
n'a pas l'air juifs et tout le monde
devant lui à des propos qui s élève à dl
voilà justement c'est ça qu'il aime
c'est ça il comme il n'a pas l'air lui
tout le monde lui vient des propos
antisémites et alors là il ya des scènes
extrêmement saine où il fait l'amour
avec une femme antisémite ce monsieur à
ce monsieur
ce monsieur a semble avoir toujours plus
beaucoup aux femmes
ah oui mais ça va en parler alors allah
en effet il ya aussi la scène de ceux de
ce copains d'université quand vous avez
réussi à devenir président du mali qui
est très laid oui oui la ville et un
soir et il vous dit
chatroom quand même c'est embêtant
d'être juif et lui dit je le regarde il
est s'il est si moche et il a trouvé une
façon de mettre supérieur exactement je
savais ce niveau j'ai dîné avec monsieur
seul l autre soit et il était très
gentil parce que il a lu le livre et
j'ai été étonné par ce que il m'a
expliqué ce que j'ai fait dans la vie
vraie parce que moi c'est vraiment moi
j'écris instinctivement j'ai écrit et il
m'a analyser et même j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses dans mon prochain
je peux devenir écrivain je suis de
nature philippe sollers à des scénarios
à placer à hollywood bien alors les
blessures parce qu'il ya vous êtes une
grande star mais vous avez eu des
blessures on a parlé d' antisémitisme
est par exemple cette scène
extraordinaire ou jeune homme vous
arrivez pour la première fois à
hollywood et vous allez à une partie
avec une jeune fille et vous rencontrer
henry fonda mais vous pardonnerai jamais
henry fonda ce qui s'est passé mais vous
savez quand quelqu'un contre j'ai
travaillé avec un iphone
après ça oui je n'ai rien dit mais quand
on est jeune on ne peut pas oublier les
choses qui arrivent
moi je en train d'écrire le livre j'ai
pensé que je peux voir les choses très
loin beaucoup plus cramond que je peux
voir les choses que peut-être que j'ai
fait la semaine dernier et vous parlez
de cette partie c'est quelque chose très
grave pour moi qu'on aime défendre il a
pris la jeune fille qui m'a accompagné
au parti et ils sont pas pour ella ella
et a pris pour james tour parce qu'ils
étaient des grands vedette
moi je n'étais rien j'étais en train de
je suis arrivé pour faire le premier
film on peut pas oublier ça ouais c'est
une blessure
oui c'est une blessure bien la seule à
sa vocalité venir à vos qualités
et les qualités je crois que les
téléspectateurs sont rendus compte vous
êtes toujours faire comme ça si vous
êtes volontaire opiniâtre gagneur
travailleurs c'est incroyable ce que
mais cette volonté qui est en vous avez
vu ce geste que vous faites souvent la
refête le l'avait sicile vous mais c'est
incroyable qu'est ce que l'on dit en
français avec un peu d'effort on arrive
à tous avec quelque chose comme ça mais
bien ceux javel avantages que mes fils
ils n'ont pas s'ils étaient pauvres
j'avais fait cet hommage
avantage à mon avis je crois les écrits
que mes fils il
ils ont fait plus que moi parce qu'il
était né dans influence
il y avait assez de manger il ya les
roses rouges pour demain qu'un service
nacre pec
mais c'est différent peut-être si mon
père était un acteur terre riche
peut-être jeu je commence à jouer au
polo cap sur d'autres mais quand
quelqu'un comme mes enfants travaillent
et ils ont envie de faire quelque chose
de ma vie ça je crois ce que personne ne
s'est pas exposé ce que j'ai fait ça
arrive souvent on a merry permettez moi
de vous faire remarquer c'est vrai que
votre fils michael c'est une grande
vedette aussi mais permet - neuf comme
un doux faire remarquer qui a plus de
voeux des deux fils de stars qui
réussissent que deux fils de
chiffonniers bien compris
[Musique]
d'accord il n'y a pas beaucoup de fils
de chiffonniers qui réussissent comme
vous oui il y en a peut-être pas alors
je viens je viens à bukavu aux qualités
alors sollers il a fait allusion
vous êtes un séducteur alors se lève
savez qui a la réputation d'être un
séducteur lui aussi au mans mais plus
lui ce n'est rien maintenant par rapport
à vous c'est rien mais le nombre de
femmes extraordinairement belle qui sont
passés dans vos bras
alors ça commence par pki d'higgins que
vous étiez à ce moment là un inconnu qui
était miss new york
et puis rita hayworth jen tierney
evelyne caisse marlene dietrich
anna maria pierangeli sellal vous à
mener par le bout du nez jean houde frau
for john confort etc
mais c'est fou le nom vous n'êtes pas
jaloux un peu ce n'est pas du tout parce
que choisir je vais des plus beaux oui
c'est pas juste
comment s'est pas vu donc c'est pas
juste pour nous tous les ans les
séducteurs
j'aime beaucoup comme tous les hommes
j'aime beaucoup les femmes mais si je
voudrais être
on est dans un livre de ma vie j'ai
essayé d'être très on est qu'est ce que
ça veut dire la vie la vie c'est l'amour
le monde les choses sexuelles ceux de
temps en temps j'ai écrit des choses
sexuelles parce que c'est un morceau de
moi de ma vie mais c'est seulement en
mon sens c'est pas ma vie complètement
et qu'on vous lister tous les femmes moi
aussi je suis étonné d'autant plus de
temps le plus beaux mots et cie pour sa
femme il dit dans les premiers temps
elle travaillé pour moi et maintenant
c'est moi qui travaille pour elle oui
après dans le solaire extraordinaire
cela d'autant plus qu'il y en a beaucoup
d'autres qui n'étaient pas des stars et
rhume et on voit souvent qu'ils les
préfèrent parce que en réalité
l'aventuré jean pierre dillange il est
quand même obligé pour satisfaire son
fantasme de monter à la fenêtre parce
que ça lui fait plaisir
elle veut qu'il apparaisse comme un
cambrioleur dans sa jambe ça c'est une
scène sordide
alors il dit des stars par exemple
marilyn monroe il dit que dans la vie
c'était quelqu'un d'assez quelconque et
que finalement elle arrivait toujours en
retard mais en revanche il ya beaucoup
d'histoire moi ce que j'aime ce qu'il
raconte ses histoires et beaucoup de
franchise beaucoup naturelles
connaissent bien les français c'est très
américain
c'est un bon garçon je n'oserais pas
faire les français hélas parce que lui
raconte tout ça avec beaucoup beaucoup
de naturel beaucoup de franchise est
investi au message admire sa pas
toujours peuplé l'écrivant leur mémoire
et les sens et les stars sont a en
réalité assez décevant
c'est ça qui l'est c'est ça qu'ils m'ont
sauf marlene dietrich sans doute qui est
très qui est très tendre avec lui mais
dont il dit cette chose merveilleuse
obscures
à propos de la psychologie féminine il
dit elle aimait bien quand on allait mal
et dès que vous allez mieux elle vous
aime moi c'est très très juste sur le
mur à terme et les bébés tous les femmes
sont comme ça c'est vrai la franchise de
ce livre j'aime bien ce qu'a écrit ce
matin dans le quotidien anne de gasperi
elle dit sont des souvenirs sans
scrupules sans remords sans regret sans
fausse honte et sans fausse modestie et
je trouve que c'est très bien il y avait
beaucoup d'ironie sur soi même et
beaucoup d'ironie dit cette phrase
formidable aussi ce riz thaï world il
dit les hommes veulent coucher avec
gildas et se réveille avec et
malheureusement est malade on ne peut
pas changer le scénario de sel bien
alors je autre qualité c'est que l'on
vous voit souvent dans des rôles de
bagarreur spartacus les vikings le
champion etc et vous n'aimez pas vous la
violence vous savez monsieur le pivot je
crois comme vous êtes vous vous souvenez
l'histoire de john wayne et moi quand
j'ai fait van gogh magnifique et c'était
la première fois on l'a vu et après
après le show in picture projection
projection weir après la projection
john wayne on a
en amont des gains au sol en bout en
bout d'un an il était fâché de bois il
boit tout à coup il me regarde bien il
m'a dit comment tout pour jouer gros
comme ça non qui est faible homosexuel
mais je crois que c'était c'est un euro
très intéressant je suis un acteur non
non non nous sommes macho un grand doit
jouer lé rôle des hommes très fort et
moi j'ai dit médiane et tout n'est pas
john oui tout un homme bureau il était
passé quand moi si c'est pour ça je
crois le problème pour les hackers
surtout s'il devient une star c'est il
doit savoir toujours qui est sûr je ne
suis pas parce que je ne suis pas levé
qui je suis moi même et si je commence à
oublier ça
je suis obligée dé créer un livre je
dois prendre ces assassins c'est très
important parce que comme ça on pourrait
faire perdre ou oui mais kirk douglas
vous dites dans votre livre qui après
avoir joué le rôle de van gogh
vous en avez été très marquée à la sas
et sans exception voilà sélectionné vous
avez raison parce que quand j'ai joué le
rôle d'un god c'est parce que je ne veux
pas discuter longtemps le fait d'être en
a que même des très imprécis honnête et
ne pas perdre ou gros clous c'est le
public
ils sont perdus moi comme acteur je sais
parfaitement bien ce que je fasse ce que
je fais oui ce que je fais est très bien
dire bien comment on va parce que je
suis avec mes interactions
je ne veux pas comment ce couple
oreilles dans le miroir exactement je
vais expliquer raison parce que c'est
très jeune scène je suis obligé de
couper l'oreille dans le miroir moi je
ne peux pas voir le miroir cela paraît
doit voir le miroir ma longue réflexion
comme ça je suis obligé de faire chaque
position à la fois je dois dans une
impasse et que je suis fou
mais dans le rôle qu'on vous dit c'est
le pivot dans le rôle de 20 go ma femme
elle m'a dit elle ne pouvait pas de se
porter parce que la première fois que co
gérante
je continue comme je suis 20 go et
s'était passé peut-être parce que
j'avais le visage de 20go cogiter auvers
sur oise
quand je suis arrivé avec une barbe
rouge avec les cheveux dans le costume
de van gogh il ya les gens là bas qu'ils
soient claires il reconnaît et ça me
rend fou et après impôts de tanger
commencent à imposer peut-être moi j'ai
fait les tableaux et gérad am spyder n
roll and je regarderai une fois j'étais
en train de regarder et un char de tous
les tableaux que 20 go il a fait la fête
de women et moi j'étais avec le mahb les
cheveux et général et tout à coup il est
en silence je tourne la tête il y as
peut-être 100 personnes qui étaient ces
régions
on va voir aussi que vous êtes un acteur
très impliqué très intelligent qui
travaillent bien ses rôles et dans votre
le film qui vous a fait venette qui
s'appelle le champion vous jouiez un
rôle de boxeur
vous racontez dans le cas avec l'actrice
marilyn maxwell vous avez un moment une
scène de violence c'est à dire qu'elle
est racontée ce que vous dites dans leur
façon de trouver oui c'est ça ça fait 7
me plaît beaucoup parce que c'était le
commencement
vraiment avant ça j'ai fait plus effet
on les traitera femmes mais j'adorerais
de faire le film
le champion passé d'abord on a fait les
gens à penser que ceux-ci fou parce
qu'ils ont pensé et ils m'ont dit que il
est un gros avec gregory peck avec yves
ugalde avec mgm
beaucoup de gens pensent que ce n'était
pas fait pour moi et j'ai dit non je ne
veux pas le jouer
ne pose pourquoi j'ai dit qu'il ya un
petit rôle dans un film c'est simple le
tchèque qui va la faire
il n'y a rien comme un gage
c'est quoi jeudi il n'y a pas d'argent
ils pensent que je suis fou mais je
voudrais jouer c'est trop mais vous vous
parlez des cons on est ensemble voilà et
on discute comment on doit fait une
scène c'était écrit dans le scénario que
je je prends les cheveux demeure maxwell
et j'ai presque envie presse la tête
contre le mieux
j'ai dit souhaité je suis un boxeur
quand je prends une femme qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
et pendant le temps que il on ne discute
et l'appel mais hélas ferment comme ça
et moi j'ai fait comme ça et là des who
et voilà c'est comme ça qu'on est à 1 et
après ça j'ai pris le monde mais 30 au
monde j'ai dit non tu ne peux pas le
faire
tu vas rester tranquillement ici parce
que si tu fais quelque chose d'autre tu
vas rester dans un hôpital longtemps ça
c'est beaucoup plus à combien je vous
arrête je vous propose de regarder cette
scène
extrait du champion voici la scène qui
venait de raconter on avec marilyn
maxwell et donc kirk douglas
oui extrait du champion
wen
[Musique]
golden bear quoi c'est bien tombé en
arrêt comme un tel âge mais je comprends
qu'elle de glace quand même quand on
vous voit comprendre toutes les femmes
étaient quand même heureuse de vous là à
vous l'avez vu l'attaqué vous êtes vous
êtes retrouvé
vous avez expliqué formidable maintenant
de trouver les choses c'est bien c'est
ce film qui vous a rendu célèbre je
crois oui bon maintenant je demande à
jacques séguéla qui est notre expérience
tard je lui ai demandé s'il faisait
répéter ce qu'il a dit chez jean pierre
elkabbach ce matin à savoir que kirk
douglas et dépose une star je dois dire
que j'ai été j'ai failli tomber de ma
chaise quand j'ai entendu ça voulez vous
répéter ça devant l'intéressé mais bien
sûr nous sommes bien joué et je crois
qu'il va partager d'ailleurs mon analyse
c'est un immense acteur
évidemment après d'ailleurs le mode et
art aux états unis n'a pas la même
signification qu'en france donc il faut
bien qu'ils comprennent les choses en
fait une star pour moi est un porte va
leur à la différence d'ailleurs d'une
vedette qui simplement il est une grande
célébrité
la star en plus rarement donnée illustre
une valeur brigitte bardot c'est la
libération de la femme par exemple john
wayne a illustré le band américain et
clar belle car geybels a illustré la
beauté de l'amérique mais lui a choisi
la colère et la colère n'est pas une
valeur et toute sa vie a été concentrée
sur la colère parfois la violence même
parfois la méchanceté il dit je préfère
être le méchant parce que le méchant est
photogénique
il a d'ailleurs tout à fait raison une
star est finalement le miroir de nos
fantasmes une série la personne à qui on
pense et
qui vous ouvrent des petites fenêtres
vers l'imaginaire pas pierre douglas
dans le premier temps de sa carrière
comme tous les jeunes premiers il a fait
rêver toutes les minettes du monde
mais dans le deuxième temps de sa
carrière ce qui reste de nuit c'est
cependant si vous avez vu ce qui reste
de lui céline ans ça c'est normal mais
vu ce qui reste de lui oui oui oui mais
mais mieux mieux vaut être à l'immense
acteur qu'une star le destin des stars
épingle
j'ai d'ailleurs lui dans une interview
qu'il a donnée il ya deux ou trois ans
dans un journal américain où il disait
finalement john wayne n'était pas un
grand acteur et il jouer en permanence
ou john wayne et c'est pour ça qu'il
était une star il dit même moi je ne
suis pas une star je suis un acteur et
j'essaye à un an donnant un grande règle
du chapitre s'intitule star mais de
savoir comment on arrive quand vous avez
décidé d'être l'homme qui décide qui est
en face alors si je me dope par exemple
vous passez les mots dans la bouche dans
ma bouche de la boucherie babouche par
cambon john wayne a mon avis oui c'est
pas une grand acteur mais il a fait les
choses comme accueil fantastique sur
aigues vives
c'était merveilleusement bien mais irait
de nous perdre ou donner l'image parce
qu'ici moi je te fait de jouer beaucoup
d'euros je ne joue pas toujours en
colère mais c'est vrai passé comme à ma
femme la première fois que l a lu mon
livre
elle m'a dit qu'elle court mais vous
êtes clairement deux contres les autres
gens mais tu es plus 2 contre 3 même
c'est moins je pense que ça c'est un
sujet c'est on me demande exactement
qu'est ce que ça veut dire une star je
suis pas sûr oui je suis prêt je sais
bien grand écrivain s'est pas découvert
après on livre un vedette n'est pas
apparent
il s'agissait pour le base si je veux
dire un mot voilà moi je crois que si
une star c'est quelqu'un qui se prend
pour son image pour qu'ils s'identifient
avec son image dans la société
spectaculaire dans laquelle nous sommes
alors qu'avec togla ce n'est pas une
star dans ce sens là c'est un délit
n'est pas comme john wayne comme il l'a
dit tout à l'heure qui se prend pour
james où il n'est pas que lui ne se
prend pas pour kirk douglas ce qui lui
donne des qualités humaines
pardonnez-moi de profondeur tout à fait
extraordinaire c'est une valeur première
valeur la deuxième valeur à l'été
avaient été financés au butin je
m'excuse que vous l'ayez pas remarqué
c'est que c'est quelqu'un qui est fidèle
à ses origines et qui étant donné son
parcours reste je crois distincts de
tout le spectacle les images parce qu'il
est fidèle tout simplement parce qu'il
est juif et que sa valeur là il l'a dit
tout le temps avec beaucoup beaucoup de
fermeté mais peur j'ai peur non pour
faire croire que dans cette émission ce
soir je vais trouver que je suis pro
stars et vous savez la star pour que
votre seul mérite d'être juive je vais
quand il est resté fidèle à sa à travers
beaucoup beaucoup diront ce qu'ils
veulent mais la star dans la définition
que j'ai voulu donner des stars qui
d'ailleurs remarquer le rarement des
vies exemplaires
les stars mènent des vies de patachon
les stars vont d'abord à mener une vie
de patachon et sa maintenance de vie
mais non mais non enfin c'était un homme
qui est amoureux de sa femme depuis 30
ans qui mène mais vivent les l'âge
paisible enfin bouriat mélanie dallaire
qui dit d'ailleurs dans son livre les
stars n'ont pas d'enfant rejettent leurs
enfants on ne connaît pas les enfants
des stars les caches noirs écouter
jusqu'au bout elle les reconnaît
moi je vais vous dire pour moi pour moi
c'est une star tout simplement ou
simplement parce que c'est un
chiffonnier
il est devenu un des plus grands acteurs
du 20e siècle il a tourné dans des
outils sont des shaders et jeu et
maintenant les spécialistes finir et au
jour il est en france depuis quelques
jours
et en quelques jours tous les journaux
se sont arrachés et douglas toutes les
émissions de télévision voulait la voir
et je vais vous dire j'ai reçu
aujourd'hui d'écouter est-ce que je
pourrais pas aller à l'émission pour le
touché pour loire c'est ça une star ce
niveau non non c'est votre non non il
n'a pas raison c'était parce que jésus
jeunes écrivains des murs bon allez on
va dire je vous donnais à paroles tout à
l'heure le c'est vrai que la franchise
dont vous parlez pas de raul gauche que
vous n'avez pas beaucoup alors que nous
on aime beaucoup et c'est bon stanley
kubrick
il ya un long passage etc stanley
kubrick et c'est vrai que grâce à vous
il a pu démarrer comme dire et vous
dites un sale con qui a du talent oui
c'est très important pour moi ça c'est
la vérité même il soit j'ai parlé avec
bent a manié il m'a raconté l'histoire
pire que moi j'ai écrit dans mon dos
dans mon livre mais les points que je
voudrais faire c'est le talon c'est pas
cela ne fait rien avec le personnage
vous savez ce qui veut dire vivement
hollande pourrait être très gentil mais
il n'a pas de talent maintenant pour
avoir beaucoup de talent mais il est un
con et ça c'est un scoop
elle a beaucoup de talent et de mireval
crise vous pensez de 2,2 du livre de
douglas et bien d'une part je lui disais
tout à l'heure en arrivant il m'a aidé à
passer deux jours il ya là il ya quinze
jours j'ai découvert son livre aux états
unis j'aimerais passer deux jours
délicieux j'étais un peu malade gtc
séjour on sent un peu inférieur en
dessous de soi même on a besoin d'une
présence amicale
alors pendant deux jours j'ai lu ce
livre 500 m'arrêter et j'ai trouvé cette
présence amicale parce que j'ai trouvé
un homme un homme nombre de boutons bout
et accessoirement iter
j'ai trouvé oui mais les stars ça ne
passionne pas tellement bien je préfère
des hommes est d'accord mais je
n'attaque osama chose la plus important
d'apprendre et voilà bien et vous avez
montré que vous étiez 1
et pas uniquement parce que vous êtes
juif sabbatique c'est le principal mais
aussi parce que vous avez un sens de
l'humour vous raconter les anecdotes
merveilleuse il ya des tas de choses bon
si on avait le temps les radios elles le
soir des jumeaux du chien qui fait ouaf
ouaf quand on décroche le téléphone mais
et puis aussi elles reviennent chose qui
a beaucoup touché
mais en jeu ne pas seulement dans votre
livre mais dans votre action en général
c'est que vous avez pris une position
très ferme en faveur des personnes âgées
et que notre monde moderne les personnes
âgées sont non seulement oublié mais
d'une certaine manière méprisé repoussé
alors qu'être un patriarche pendant des
millénaires ça était être quelqu'un de
bien en fait on espérait presque la
vieillesse pour devenir quelqu'un
d'important et maintenant les vieillards
sont traités comme une espèce de rebuts
de détritus ce et vous avez le courage
de venir de là le maccarthysme oui cette
période noire des états unis
oui où il a eu le courage de faire
signer deux oui c'est très important et
nous sommes tous courage le courage
c'est normal non
tout le monde le sait j'étais courage
politique je suis un héros récité des
poèmes d'enfants vous avez écrit que
vous étiez enfant
vous les avez gardé en mémoire ou bien
où les avait gardés dans vos archives en
mai - en mémoire quelle mémoire et bien
et puis j'aime bien dans vos débuts
évidemment vous racontez vos débuts à
broadway retirant thrombose et petits
rôles et un jour on vous a proposé
d'être le télégraphiste ou et chantant
des graphistes qui chantait vous vous
rappelez ce qu'on veut on vous a fait
chanter un télégramme mais a su sur quel
air sage et chanter c'est un travail que
j'avais au théâtre il y as presque
peut-être 45 ans c'est votre premier
mais bien le ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire c'est quand on lit ce
livre c'est qu'évidemment le visage de
kirk douglas nous a tellement familier
c'est que on peut plaquer
ce visage sur chacune des actions qui
rendra compte on en dise ce livre c'est
pas seulement un livre c'est un film
c'est un film où on voit toujours kirk
douglas et à propos de films vous
raconter une soir dans un restaurant
vous a été pris d'un malaise
on vous a en vous emmener et en vos amis
je sais pas le goutte-à-goutte etc et
vous vous crier non non pas du tout je
suis ce film j'ai déjà vu ces mauvais il
faut pas jouer dans ce film c'est vrai
c'est vrai pas souvent la vie et je
crois pas toujours pour les hackers
peut-être pour les autres aussi la vie
est comme on joue mouche l'avait comme
une forme de l'anecdote c'est pas vrai
une anecdote merveilleuse c'est quand y
voit un jour il voit une fille et il se
dit à l'aise il est vraiment très belle
je vais être bogarde et je vais allumer
ma cigarette comme lui et je vais passer
près d'elle je vais lui dire dans 10
minutes dans la voiture et il fait ça et
il est beau garde et il dit j'ai été
bogarde toute la nuit
il ya place ce très bon coach
jean-philippe va venir dans un petit
moment et la conversation coach
jean-philippe c'est notre spécialiste du
ciné club il va parler avec vous dans un
moment j'ai alors maintenant c'est à
vous sollers évidemment c'est pas un
cadeau de passer derrière kiev nous
glace j'ai bien géré mon gars ça qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de la réponse que
sollers a fait dans votre livre
je trouve qu'elle est qu'elle est
particulièrement saint-serge été frappée
d'ailleurs de voir à quel point ça je ne
pensais pas du tout à quel point salers
était sensible à la critique
voilà je pensais pas que des articles et
dieu sait s'ils n'en suscitent à
parfois un peu dur pouvait le toucher et
dans ce texte assez courts du
dictionnaire je trouve qui montre aussi
son vrai visage
oui c'est bien c'est pas un texte
plaintif j'ai plutôt humoriste 18 mai au
zoo louis sa part dans un avion se
traduit non plus mais c'est à dire que
la plus la plupart des articles que je
lis sur moi dans ton aucun rapport il
faudrait que je le dise avec les livres
que j'ai écrits
ils sont même truffé d'erreurs sur la
lecture mais enfin ne suscitant pas y at
il encore de la critique littéraire je
ne sais pas par rapport aux leaders dont
qui même paraître j'ai vu des armes aux
mains ou en vous et rentes
oui notre article pour vous loue oui
c'est ça oui c'est vrai c'est toujours
envie de ses 13 ans et patrick sont des
vrais événements puis d'autres où on
ferait on fait pour ce trail of ages est
drôle ça n'est pas une chose qui est
satisfaisante aussi pour un auteur que
d'être à moitié louer et et moitié
vilipendé oui ça fait longtemps que ça
dure mais en effet c'est assez
satisfaisant s'est toujours fié
d'ailleurs avec des renversements
spectaculaire et dans votre les carnets
de nuit vous y revenez on emploiera
contre toi vous par exemple tous les
moyens successivement aussi mais aussi
multi naiman censure marginalisation
récupération academy nation bouffonne
isation et ses six co est la raison
garcin vous avez quand même vous avez la
peau fragile
donc c'est pas que j'ai la peau fragile
mais je crois qu'elle écrivait
aujourd'hui ne subsistent dans le dans
le monde du spectacle généralisée où
nous sommes et où quelques personnes
lucides enfin douglas les ne subsiste
avec des
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
malentendus avec l'existence d'un
écrivain est désormais problématique
dans le dictionnaire de jérôme garcin on
voit très bien que tous ces écrivains
sont saisi soit par une par une
nécessité de justification soit par une
sorte de réserve enfin du bon bah ils ne
sont pas très à l'aise c'est oui mais
vous arrivez dans notre société n'est
pas très zen bien sûr pourquoi parce
qu'elle est spectaculaire et parce que
les écrivains sont il faut aller vite
donc on ne lit pas vraiment les livres
et bientôt peut-être plus personne je
vous ai lu attentivement
merci je vous ferai remarquer que par
exemple vous cultivez malgré toi plaisir
les malentendus les esquives les
dérapages les provocations
c'est une façon ironique oui mais alors
il ya justement cette page 108 dans vos
carnets vous dit la phrase que tu
sollers devra barre et si tu publies ce
quart mais évidemment vous le publiez le
carnet et il se trouve et c'est je dois
tout à la prière oui alors autrement dit
vous dites ne faut pas que je passe si
je publie ça les gens vont gloser là
dessus nouveau nom nouveau malentendu
mais voulez pas vous la publier quand
même ça c'est de la rhétorique 1
c'est-à-dire ont fini par dire
exactement ce qu'on veut tout en disant
qu'on ne devrait peut-être pas le dire
dans ses carnets aussi vous dites je
suis pour les calmants tous les calmants
éloge de la morphine
oui parce que la douleur et la chose
probablement la plus importante de la
vie humaine
je crois qu'elle n'a pas d'autre c'est
finalement la souffrance est pas
tellement la mort c'est le fait de
souffrir et quiconque a eu je ne sais
pas - une rapide dans l'épouvantable qui
a souffert le martyre enfin ça ça vaut
aussi pour les mourants
je crois que la mort film paraît le
produit le plus merveilleux du monde ce
que j'ai tort je pense pas oui mais
quelques pages plus loin vous parlez du
haschich les lignes rituel des joints
oui mais ça c'est vraiment ça j'espère
que tout le monde comprend non non
[Rires]
ce sont des expériences de jeunesse son
expérience de jeunesse est bien ailleurs
d'ailleurs douglas a dit un jour qu'il a
il a commencé à prendre un petit peu de
choses comme ça mais finalement ça n'a
pas joué un rôle très important dans ses
locaux
on n'a pas joué un rôle très important
très très rare mais jamais jamais moi
non plus là je viens au leader vous
dites ça c'est le personnage comment
vous n'avez pas une machine à traitement
de texte saimone mais c'est incroyable
vous ne savez pas de quoi vous vous
privez qu'est-ce que vous êtes vieux jeu
et solaire ces vieux jeu de tenir des
carnets mais oui parce qu'il écrit tout
à la main avec un petit avec un petit
stylo et il tape eu lieu mais la machine
tout ce qu'il fait il écrit lui même ses
livres et vous ne voulez pas de machine
neutre et non parce que c'est vraiment
c'est désagréable pour la sensation ça
c'est comme si on mettait un préservatif
il paraît bien et bien entendu dans les
cars mais vous parlez du lys d'or le
roman le leader romand on est des
conversations très libre en france
télévisions américaines est moins libre
pas moins de ces choses je crois on rit
on est moins de liberté aidez le pays
dix l'étaient en carbone très vite tout
être commencer ici pourvu que ça dure le
leader dans les carnets vous parlez du
lys d'or roman histoire d'un objet
autrefois dérobé dans une église et qui
se retrouvent à sa place une toute autre
place à travers une série d' aventure
qui sont l'objet du roman oui et quand
dire de plus alors ça c'est l'histoire
d'un monsieur qui est professeur de
chinois dans un centre d'études
religieuses qui s'intéresse beaucoup au
talent et qui a joué entre autres dans
chez un antiquaire de la rue du bac qui
rencontrent là une jeune aristocrate
très très riche qui va se révéler très
riche qui s'appelle rennes de l'eau
était en train d'acheter en effet une un
lys d'or qu'a dû être un élément de
l'annonciation sculptés au monde comme
on va vous savez dans tous les tableaux
les annonciation il ya il ya un archange
qui tiens lis à la main et ce lycée de
rennes lors qu'elle achète ce produit
c'est cet objet très cher il la suit ils
ont ils ont une conversation il tombe
amoureux d'elle elle ne veut pas
avoir de relation physique avec lui mais
en revanche de diaby lui l'intérêt s'il
l'intéressent son savoir sa culture
l'intéressent et elle va avec lui signe
un contrat très curieux qui fait qui va
raconter l'histoire de la relation
l'histoire de sa vie pour elle comme
s'il s'agissait d'une oeuvre d'art qui
va rester dense et bien elle et ça va
être le roman est le récit de cette
relation très bizarre puisque c'est une
femme qui paye un homme pour raconter sa
vie c'est le contrat des mille et une
nuits si vous voulez ou
une fable raconte des histoires insultes
serpent c'est le contraire c'est donc
petit à petit land dans le roman il va
essayer de la séduire à travers ce qu'il
écrit à travers les récits qu'il fait il
ya le faire des propositions de
séduction en europe alors voilà ça
évolue petit à petit et il finalement il
va et va peut-être il va arriver à ses
fins nous n'allons pas tout dire est ce
parce qu'elle se refuse au dévergondage
le mot employé que est la droite d'une
certaine manière à travers ce livre une
sorte de marivaudage intellectuel et
culturel
il en tombe il en tombe amoureux
justement peut-être parce que parce
qu'elle se refuse peut-être que les
femmes dont on amoureux sont celles qui
se dérobent celles qui font attendre
c'est un peu là là c'est là qu'on est
pris dans l'amour au fond personne n'a
envie de tomber de tomber vraiment
amoureux il ya une double à ce dessein
nationalités qui se défend d'être
amoureux ils préfèrent des choses les
choses plus plus simple direct plus
physique et donc là c'est l'histoire
quand même d'une d'une passion amoureuse
il tombe amoureux parce que justement
elle ne veut pas donc elle le tient par
par ce contrat ne pas baiser c'est un
mot que vous employez oui on comprenait
une bd lyonnaise ne doit faire face tout
faire si je ne comprends pas je vois que
chaque fois que la main et fait comme ça
c'est un type d'acteur oui mais
autrement dit ne pas baiser encore une
fois je reprends le terme
ça veut dire c'est plus de conversation
c'est plus de culture c'est probablement
une façon de oui c'est une atmosphère de
séduction plus sophistiqués plus tu
recherchais c'est à dire en effet il ya
beaucoup de dialogue beaucoup de
conversations où ils essayent petit à
petit de l'amener quand même sur le
terrain de l'acceptation
mais la sexualité et la culture sont les
deux ressorts romanesque de solaire vous
et moi je me déteste ni la culture de la
sexualité la culture on sait que
quelqu'un dit quelque chose de ses
lèvres quand j'entends le mot je sors
d'un revolver et quand
le mot sexualité non plus ne provoque
pas chez moi là la censure et je crois
en plus que les deux choses sont
extraordinairement liés c'est à dire que
tous les phénomènes culturels sont des
phénomènes de sexualité plus ou moins
déguisés c'est une banalité
alors j'essaye c'est ça dans tous les
romans j'essaye de montrer à quel point
ces deux choses là sont toujours très
très imbriquées et il n'y a pas de
culture sans sexualité réciproquement
gars humble jugement sur solaires
solaire ce roman sur son herbe face à
verser ou non le roman est une star
sollers
ah oui tiens pourquoi est ce que c'est
une star c'est là c'est nada c'est
certainement une star de l'avenir mais
non ça suffit comme ça mais on peut se
battre sur ce bien ton nom
nous sommes dans cette époque médiatique
qui a beaucoup plus cultes et les stars
de l'écrit pour laisser la place aux
stars du business du sport garcin ou de
la politique
je pense que la seule histoire de
salaire c'est la dernière
cette dernière présentant de la vie
littéraire avec ce cas-là de foot de
parfois de d'énervant parfois de
superbes mais c'est là bien c'est une
des slas de la visitation pour ça que je
l'invité je sais bien c'est parce que
effectivement il ça fait 30 ans alors il
faut vous dire vous le savez peut-être
pas vous savez beaucoup de choses nous
c'est peut-être pas c'est qu'il ya 30
ans il a été lancé par deux articles
signés aragon et l'autre françois
mauriac deux des plus grands écrivains
français du xxème siècle donc ce petit
jeune homme inconnu été lancés par ses
deux grands parrains voilà depuis
évidemment et ça l'a rendu célèbre du
jour au lendemain
oui garcelle sur ce roman c'est je crois
que c'est le le roman le plus difficile
de sollers
moi j'ai eu ce matin à coups de
téléphone avec mes confrères je sais
qu'il ya plus de critiques littéraires
en france qu'elles disent toutes les
stars de la littérature et c'est un côté
fun qui m'a troublé parce que ce
confrère éminent m'a donné des clés que
j'avais pas trouvé bon ce qui était
d'ailleurs un peu inquiétant pour moi ou
pour la critique littéraire
je n'ai pas trouvé donc il ya des clés
moi je sais pas j'ai lu j'ai lu ce livre
sans me préoccuper des clients toujours
des pièges oui mais si j'ai des clans
apport aux livres précédents de sollers
qui était lisible et a sans doute être
plus linéaire il y avait un peu moins
trivial pursuit là il ya des choses et
on s'intéresse minnesota si on n'a pas
les cartes et g il m'a dit il m'a dit
voilà pas chance je me suis jeté sur la
page 111 effectivement j'ai vu qu'il ya
un truc que j'avais pas compris
voilà c'est aussi un jeu du terrain on
peut le lire sans concurrence à voir
aussi mais on peut aussi ce qui est ce
qui est le cas de ce livre là faire des
ponctions lombaires
on peut prendre des passages il ya des
délires qui prouve que c'est très
travaillé et on pouvait nous dit que
c'est un artiste de l'insaisissable quoi
c'est complet oui beaucoup parce que je
crois que la littérature c'est toujours
quelque chose qui laisse en suspens la
réalité qui essayent de la passionnée et
qui en même temps ne porte pas de
jugement qui essaye de montrer que tout
ça est un jeu extrêmement fin le jour où
tout sera saisie savent y aura plus de
littérature bien donc le leader et
qu'avait de nuit et on va terminer donc
avec jacques séguéla demain il sera trop
tard maintenant avec les stars oui vous
dit d'entrée j'aime les stars et on se
dit séguéla il est moitié groupies
moitié midi nati oui pourquoi aimer même
temps les stars parce qu'elles nous font
rêver et que je suis un homme d'
imaginaires que finalement la publicité
c'est la mise à jour c'est la mise en
pratique quotidienne de l'imaginaire et
que je crois qu'on les a un peu délaissé
et que c'est elle qui dans les moments
les plus défaitistes de notre vie sont
là pour nous remettre sur le chemin et
se sont surtout parce que ce sont des
portes valeur elle qui trace notre route
quand se trouvent deux stars et tout
d'un coup le monde se trompe de route
les stars qu'ils sont
vous faites des portraits d'ailleurs
certains sont assez savoureux par
exemple sinatra donc montant sinatra
pour vous ça c'est des stars qui ne sont
pas contestables c'est évident chacun à
sa liste de stars je voudrais pas que
pierre douglas partent en disant je suis
pas le star pas dans ma définition à moi
mais moi j'ai plein d'autres personnes
il va être une star
ah oui moi j'ai d'ailleurs à chacun sa
liste ayant ces montants ne sont pas que
ça
si d'ici six ans oui mais trente
secondes 30 secondes expliqué on est
d'abord starlette
il faut de la notoriété à tout prix et
là on est prêt à tout pour être connu et
puis on devient vedette
c'est dire qu'on est une célébrité on
est connu mais on n'est pas accroché à
une valeur on devient star lorsque en
plus de cette célébrité on est porteur
d'une valeur
si cette valeur devient l'aspiration
d'une génération on devient 8
brigitte bardot est un mythe parce
qu'elle est lé l'illustrent la
libération de la femme
jammes dean est un mythe parce que ils
illustrent la liberté rebelles et c'est
là où j'ai dit que pierre douglas est un
immense acteur et que l'homme fascine et
j'ai adoré son livre et j'ai vu tous ses
films d'un foie mais pour moi il n'est
pas une star mais ça n'est pas du tout
je ratisse une méchanceté est péjoratif
je crois qu'au contraire rien n'est pire
que la vie de star lorsque j'ai dédicacé
mon livre à mon fils je bedie pour te
garder un jour d'être star
j'aurais envie de lui dire comme il l'a
dit à ses fils pour devenir de grands
acteurs ou de grands producteurs parce
que la star sacrifie sa vie à sept
valeurs qu'elle porte aux qu'elle
représente est généralement les grandes
stars sont de mauvais acteurs brigitte
bardot qui est la plus grande star
française aujourd'hui a pas brillé dans
ce rôle elle a brillé dans on peut faire
quand même dire que c'est la plus grande
actrice française qu'elle avait fait
rayonner la wii elle avait beaucoup de
talent elle avait le talent je n'avais
pas l'idée m'a insulté
mais les casques bleus des badauds n'a
pas de talent comme acteur qui est
formulée
je pense que ce n'est pas son talent
d'acteur qui a fait qu'elle est en train
de devenir un mythe c'est à dire qu'elle
restera après sa mort pour avoir porté
un moment donné l'espoir d'une
génération qui des années 60 55 aux
années 80 s'est libéré et finalement
s'est affirmée et accepter d'être elle
même et c'est ce phénomène sociologique
qui fait que en plus de l'actrice en
plus de la femme elle est devenue autre
chose bon je crois que vous et c'est
parce que vous êtes
et c'est parce que vous êtes cette
espèce de torrents intérieur de cette
violence continue et cette intensité que
je crois vous avez refusé la vie de star
les stars affichent leur vie en
permanence et vous croyez qu'à paris il
mène pas une vie de star il était au
ritz avec les y arriver tout avant le
nom c'est une fortune à son éditeur erp
fortune mosher pivot ne confondez pas
tout il mène une vie médiatique
extraordinaire mais maintenant est ce
que l iphone star oui est ce que vous
gagnez comment elle avait en talons je
suis à l'abri
j'ai pensé je les trouvais rien mais
devant l'appareil seul écran mais ces
regrets de fantastic 1 avec talent
fantastique mais sa vie a eu du talent
et d'ailleurs sa vie a été dramatique et
à l'infini d'une façon dramatique de
quelques pilules de trop ou d'un mystère
que l'on ne connaîtra jamais les stars
vivent de mystère ne connais pas leur
vie et surtout elle s'arrête un moment
donné elles ne finissent pas leur vie et
je trouve que le courage d'ailleurs de
l'acteur d'écrire son livre d'ailleurs
vous parlez jamais ou très peu
de votre vie de stars vous parler avant
tout de votre métier d'acteur de votre
vie d'homme de votre vie de père notre
vie d'allemand mais vous n'êtes pas du
tout obsédé par écrit un livre comment
on peut l'écrire je vais écrire mais
veut parce que je suis pour ce qui est
intéressant est créé pour ça qui est
intéressant ce sont les jeunes ans d'art
généralement ne sont pas très
intéressants et dieu sait que j'en ai lu
et des centaines séguéla vous observez
aussi un déplacement d'intérêt
d'hollywood vers wall street
alors d'où la présence est la raison de
votre ligne à travers les stars pour
essayer d'y voir clair puisque voyais
bien que personne n'arrive à être
d'accord sur la définition d'une star je
me suis aperçu que finalement il n'y
avait pas que les stars de cinéma car ce
petit écran qui est un mangeur de stars
à inventer de nouvelles stars il a
d'abord inventé des stars politiques qui
sont devenus des stars comme les acteurs
et dont certains deviennent limite alors
vous parlez de françois mitterrand
françois mi-temps de gorbatchev qui est
certainement la plus grande star des
années à venir
et puis les sportifs car on les a vus
tous les dimanches à la télévision
latini et pelé avec une difficulté qui
est que pelé réussi à être une double
star il a été la star extraordinaire de
la virtuosité du ballon et c'est devenu
un homme d'affaires extraordinaire qui
continue de rayonner à travers le nom ce
que platini est en train de rater et
puis les stars de télévision qui sont
des noms stars adam lacko niveau norge
écoutez je suis parfaitement d'accord je
considère qu'il ya la télévision ne fait
pas destin n'y a pas de star à la
télévision je suis tout à fait d'accord
quand vous dites
la star c'est la chaîne absolument
parfaitement de votre avis les stars de
télévision ne sont que des locataires
tout à fait l'histoire de la notoriété
de lâcher tout à fait d'accord je suis
pas d'accord avec certains passages
valley mais là
hier pleinement les jetons sur cette
question je ne suis pas d'accord avec
pas d'accord mais je crois il est
beaucoup de gens qui devient une star
pas télévision suis moi même mon fils
m'a fait les frais cisco oui mais ça
c'est la fiction mais ça c'est la
finition des présentateurs de télévisé
présenté des journalistes voilà oui vous
avez raison la télévision
ford il a progressé un peu peut-être
idiote mais peut-être pas si une diète
que ça
pourquoi est ce qu'on dit une star et
par un star pourquoi est-ce que le
concept reste à réfléchir est une étoile
et que c'est justement une sorte de
planètes inaccessible qui est là haut
qu'on peut pas toucher qui brille donc
serré femina le potentiel d'une star it
et d'ailleurs certaines stars son prénom
féminines c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
dans ma catégorie pardon je ne traite
pas ça parce qu'il est tellement mal
tellement viril il est jeune et non
jaune lourd avec yves ethève et oui oui
c'est à dire éviter qu'il fait il a
incarné la mairie l'émission herrmann il
faut que l'émission s'arrête parce que
je vais beaucoup débordé autrement alors
benedetti peut-être oui parce que l'on
est dans le public qui décide qui est
entendue mais le public nous aime
évidemment et je crois qu'ils préfèrent
les acteurs canesta donc n'essayez pas
de changer de titre dans la
classification à moi rester
l'extraordinaire avant d'être et
artistes
alors on arrive aux stars de la finance
minister du guide les stars du business
ils sont les stars d'aujourd'hui les
tapis les iacocca aux états unis les
nerfs et dénis et seront elles les stars
de demain et c'est le cri d'alarmé que
j'essaye de pousser dans ce livre en dix
ans arrêtons-nous et mea culpa j'ai été
le premier à pousser la roue a essayé de
faire que ces grands patrons prennent la
place les stars de l'imaginaire
les stars de cinéma ou des stars de la
littérature nous faisons fausse route
essayons de passer dans ce moment très
très rare de la sociologie française où
l'on est sur le fil du rasoir d'une
société fric
regardez toutes les affaires en ce
moment et d'une société coeur essayons
nous qui sommes les communicants les
journalistes les critiques de
publicitaires dans leur petit dans leur
petit coin
essayons de faire basculer le monde vers
la société coeur en revenant aux grandes
stars de l'imaginaire les acteurs les
peintres les musiciens les écrivains oui
les balades les poètes moi j'en fais que
lorsqu'elle avait 20 ans enfin les stars
s'appelait cocteau les stars s'appelait
prévert mais ça ressemble et sarthe
et aujourd'hui je suis désolé mais ça
s'appelle tapis ou iacocca on est je
suis en plus à mentir et responsable on
marche sur la tête et permettez moi nous
faire remarquer qu'il ya quand même eu
déjà des chefs d'entreprise et dans le
passé ont été de grandes stars jouent
citerai andré citroën qui a été une star
fantastique au milieu du siècle qui
étaient vraiment excités à l'exception
oui les synthés en train de devenir
l'arrêt cela dit je suis très content
vous entendre dire qu'il faudrait que
redevienne star les acteurs et non plus
les les gens de wall street suite à fait
d'accord et j'ai le très content qu'à la
main qui était à la place de monsieur
volkov quinze jours disait que lui qui
est un financier dix militaires
maintenant pour une europe culturel pour
une europe des artistes de la création
bravo parce que l'argent ne fait pas
rêver mais le rêve fait de l'argent
alors quelques ouvrages de terminer je
vous signale ce dictionnaire qui est
formidable éditions bordas sous la
direction de gilles horvilleur c'est le
dictionnaire des personnages du cinéma
et bien entendu vous êtes dedans ça va
de soi kirk douglas et alors on
s'arrange mais est-ce que je suis une
star
écoutez star non c'est pas marqué c'est
pas mal non mais alors on renvoie quant
à l'or à la fin la table des matières il
ya douglas kirk et à saran voir
alcoolique amputé architectes avocats
bagnard borgne boxeur chef cinéaste
cowboys journaliste mineurs mutinés
paysans peintre moi c'est vous
vous êtes reconnu la wii bien alors je
signale deux baffes fait tomber les
ouates ge pardon que le coeur absolu le
précédent roman de type solaire vient de
paraître dans la collection folio
et puis à propos de jacques séguéla
parce que c'est grâce une star parce
qu'on vit à maignon millions de dinars
et qui n'est pas le seul justement alors
écoutez qui peut se vanter d'avoir un
livre sur la langue ne laissait pas
repartir en personne on est une star et
pas lui alors là à la fin du championnat
qui recommence je rentre pas chez moi
oui alors marcel germain qui est un
éminent publicité a consacré un livre à
jacques séguéla c'est ça quand même
alors ça s'appelle d'ailleurs scapin de
génie à ce qu'apple génie là c'est quand
même pas rien et avec une préface de
michel côté a paru aux éditions me lire
albatros et c'est le récit de votre vie
et puis surtout laury's ablement
documentés où le document a participé
qui formidablement bien fait il est très
bien fait parce que je gerbe ont
d'ailleurs écrit très bien et que les
comm ca publicitaire clavien publicité
et puis vous aime beaucoup il faut pas
le cacher les publicitaires formidable
publicitaires et puis je sonia elle va
du mal de pub dans la collection de
solaires ce qui n'augure sollers dirigée
par alain weinstein co roseraie l'autre
jour à un poste par m
trois autres livres dans la collection
chez plon marque le bot une blessure au
pied des dix petits états marque bleue
botte est un intellectuel et écrit
beaucoup d'articles dans la presse
valerio adami le pam bien entendu les
règles du montage et pierre riboulet qui
est un architecte naissance d'un hôpital
donc tout ça dans la collection car
mêmes éditions plon toujours avec
sollers et le dernier leur livraison de
sa revue l'infini sollers bataille fait
donc quand même sollers bataille fellini
plein est moi je mettrais que vous
mettrez en dernier quand même là je
mettrais quand même bataille fellini
plein soleil on n'a pas dû y penser mais
là chez gallimard là il dit ça y est les
solaires c'est la star donc on le met en
premier quand même et puis préfacé par
jérôme garcin des poèmes les mains nues
de michel baglin c'est un recueil qui a
obtenu le prix max pol fouchet qui est
publié aux éditions l'âge d'homme c'est
de la bonne poésie voilà alors à propos
de toujours de stars - remy c'est le
journal de romy schneider qui paraît aux
éditions michel lafon
et puis de frédéric mitterrand qui
travaillent sur cette chaîne comme vous
le savez est un grand spécialiste du
cinéma des stars
et donc de qui connaît très bien qu'à me
douglas et les numéros un du cinéma un
frédéric mitterrand et bien entendu une
page bien documenté est très bien
illustré est consacrée à kirk douglas et
à beaucoup d'autres acteurs réalisateurs
etc
et puis toujours publié par jean marc
lech et michel chiffres voici ainsi sont
ils sont trés et portrait de 89 élus aux
états généraux de la notoriété française
voilà alors il ya tout là dedans il ya
des il ya des sportifs il y a des gens
de la télévision des écrivains des
journalistes déchets des hommes
d'affaires des des publicitaires via
dubaï sera trop tard je parle j'ai pas
regardé comment voir comment évidemment
il ya vous comment vous solaire sais pas
je suis 6,6 au lait ce verset ski à
kirkouk si philippe sollers alors est-ce
qu'on voit yakir à l'aube l'ajax et il y
à jacques séguéla et philippe soler
suivi je me souviens que je les lui il
ya quinze jours ou trois semaines il ya
chaque seuil est là et philippe sollers
alors vous n'y êtes pas mais parce que
vous n'êtes pas français c'est pour ça
comment vous en sortir
voilà et puis à peu j'ai présenté le
roman de louis blériot sacré paul
plumieux édition olivier orban et mardi
soir à strophes j'ai présenté de nicole
casanova l'oiseau vert du bonheur aux
éditions belfond et puis je vous signale
un petit peu de retard mais quand on
reçoit des stars comme kirk douglas
j'ai l'autorisation d'antenne 2 2
d'avoir quelques minutes en plus voilà
alors et je signale que sur le minitel
36 que 36 15 codes apos démarre
aujourd'hui un jeu de cinéma jeu
évidemment de connaissances s'appelle
cinéma posse et on vous pose des
questions aussi bien sur les livres de
cinéma que bien entendu sur les films
par exemple ya cette question quel
cinéaste a écrit un best seller dont il
a tiré le film l'arrangement avec kirk
douglas et faye dunaway
alors est-ce arthur miller s elia kazan
où s
anthony mann s'est il ya 15 ans et alors
ça c'est plus compliqué qu elle est
l'auteur du livre spartacus adapté à
l'écran par stanley kubrick avec kirk
douglas
s eric cannes s arthur koestler ou ace
awards face et bien sûr pas de face mais
tous les trois ans un cri un spartacus
ils ont tous les trois écrivains
spartacus voilà eh bien
et on voit d'autres embauches alors on
danse et on se retrouve tout de suite
avec l'eau de jean-philippe dans
quelques instants après le générique de
fin d'émission bonsoir à tous et à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]